This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个由I-Heart制作的播客。真实可靠的人类。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那确实是个疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here.
大家好，欢迎回到《20s的心理学》，在这里我们探讨20岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的20岁意味着什么，对我们的心理又意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴能在这里见到你们。
New listeners, old listeners. Oh, yeah. How exciting. Thanks for joining us for another really fabulous exciting episode. One that I am so excited to have been able to research and all the things that I found out are just so interesting. So thank you so much for tuning in. And if you didn't know, this episode was actually chosen by you guys, by my listeners.
新听众，老听众。哦，是的。太令人兴奋了。感谢你们加入我们又一期精彩绝伦、令人兴奋的节目。这一期我非常高兴能够亲自去查资料，我发现的所有事情都太有趣了。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你还不知道，这一期节目其实是由你们——我的听众们选出来的。
I recently hit a million listens, which is just absolutely mind-blowing, like, insanely overwhelming. I don't think I've quite processed it yet. So thank you so much for supporting the show and for listening to it. It really does just blow my mind that this thing that I started as a hobby, people want to listen to. So thank you so much. To kind of celebrate, I was like, let's let you choose the episode. So I posted on my Instagram
我最近的收听量突破了一百万，这简直太不可思议了，可以说是疯狂地让人应接不暇。我觉得我到现在还没完全消化这个消息。非常感谢大家对节目的支持和收听。这真的让我大开眼界，我当初当成业余爱好开始做的事情，竟然真的有人想听。所以非常感谢大家。为了庆祝这一里程碑，我想：不如让你们来选择节目主题吧。于是我在Instagram上发帖
the episodes that I have researched and written for the next like two months essentially. I was like, what do you want to hear first? And overwhelmingly, you guys said this one. So here we are. We are going to be talking about being single, happy and alone in our 20s. I also want to thank my subscribers, my paid subscribers. For those of you who do not know, I release bonus episodes like once a month. That might be an interview or a let's get friendly episode with some of my friends or a loveline or a chatty episode. So if you would like to subscribe to that and get access to bonus content, there is a link in the description. It's a really easy way to listen to more of these episodes if that's something you want to do.
列出了我接下来差不多两个月里已经做过调研和撰稿的节目主题。我问大家：你们最想听哪一个？结果毫无悬念，大家一致选择了这一个。所以我们就来了。今天我们要聊的是：在20s单身，快乐而孤独。我也要感谢我的订阅者，也就是付费订阅者。对于那些不知道的朋友，我大约每个月会发布一期额外节目。那可能是一场访谈，也可能是一期与朋友们的轻松畅聊节目，或者是一期情感热线、闲聊节目。如果你想订阅并获取独家内容，描述栏里有一个链接。如果你想收听更多此类节目，这是一个非常简单的方法。
Won't be offended if you don't, but to also support the show and allow it to grow. So thank you for those who are part of that community. It's so amazing that you want to support me, and I'm very, very grateful. But without further ado, let's get into it. I know why we're all here. We want to hear about this topic. And today, that's exactly what we're talking about. We're talking about how to be at peace with being alone and single in our 20s and the psychology behind
如果你不想订阅也没关系，我绝不会介意，但这也算是在支持节目并让它继续成长。所以感谢那些成为这个社群一员的人。你们想要支持我，这让我感到非常不可思议，我对此非常非常感激。但话不多说，我们这就切入正题。我知道我们为什么聚在这里。我们都想听听这个话题。今天，我们要聊的正是这个。我们要探讨的是如何在20s单身且独处时感到内心平静，以及这种状态背后的心理学
why we can often struggle with reality of being single, but most importantly, how to actually enjoy this period in our lives, how to flourish and discover more about ourselves, our internal worlds, our thoughts, our beliefs. I think as humans, especially in a monogamous society, in which so much of our lives and our societal expectations are focused on monogamy and obtaining love and partnership and marriage, we really crave the stability of a partner and want someone to love. And that feeling is entirely okay. It's valid. It's okay to want a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a partner because deep connections can bring us really deep joy. But I think it's also important to be okay being alone, especially when we are young and in our 20s and not let our relationship
为什么我们常常会与单身现实进行心理挣扎，但最重要的是，如何真正享受人生中的这一阶段，如何绽放自我，并更多地探索我们自己、我们的内心世界、我们的想法和我们的信念。我认为作为人类，特别是在一个一夫一妻制的社会里——在这个社会中，我们的生活和我们的社会期望有很大一部分都集中在一夫一妻制以及获得爱情、伴侣和婚姻上——我们真的非常渴望伴侣带来的稳定性，并且想要去爱某人。这种感觉完全没有问题。它是合理的。想要一个男朋友、女朋友或伴侣是没有错的，因为深度的连接能给我们带来极深的快乐。但我认为，学会享受独处同样重要，特别是在我们年轻的20岁出头时，不要让我们的恋爱
status kind of determine our worth or how much we get to enjoy life. I think romantic love is just one element of a really fulfilled joyous life. So it's something I'm really passionate about and love speaking about with my friends. How can we cultivate self-love and cultivate happiness when we find ourselves single? I think particularly in our 20s, we can feel a lot of internal and external pressure around being single and not just single, but happy with it being that way. This is especially hard in a decade like our 20s when many of the people around us, many of our friends begin meeting their life partners or getting married. And it can be a difficult point of comparison when you find yourself alone or without that person. I fall into this
状态来决定我们的价值，或者决定我们享受生活的程度。我认为浪漫的爱情仅仅是充实快乐的生活中的一个要素。所以这是我真正充满热情、并且很乐意与朋友们谈论的话题。当我们发现自己单身时，如何培养自爱，如何培养快乐？我认为尤其是在20s，对于单身这件事，以及不仅是单身、还要对这种单身状态感到快乐这件事，我们可能会感受到来自内在和外在的巨大压力。在一个像20s这样的十年里，这尤其艰难，因为我们身边许多人、我们的许多朋友开始遇到他们的人生伴侣或步入婚姻。当你发现自己孤身一人或没有那样一个人时，这很容易成为一个艰难的比较点。我经常陷入这个
trap quite a lot, especially since so many of my friends are in relationships. I remember this time, I think around this time last year when three of my closest friends, friends of the show, shout out to them, but they all entered long-term committed relationships. And I obviously love their partners. I think they're great people. And I genuinely very much enjoy their company. But it does change dynamics. And my friends have someone else to consider in their lives.
陷阱，特别是考虑到我的很多朋友都在恋爱中。我记得去年这个时候，大概是这个时候吧，我三个最要好的朋友——节目组的好朋友，给他们比个心——他们全都进入了长期且坚定的恋爱关系。我当然很喜欢他们的伴侣。我觉得他们都是很好的人。而且我也确实很享受和他们在一起的时光。但这确实改变了人际动态。我的朋友们在生活中有了另一个人需要去顾及。
And they are so amazing at prioritizing their friendships and their own lives. And obviously we're still incredibly close. but as everyone around us seems to find their person and have these fantastic love stories and experiences, has someone to adventure with and share something with, it can be really difficult to not feel like something might be wrong with us, that we are somehow undeserving, that we'll never have that,
他们非常擅长优先处理他们的友谊和他们自己的生活。而且显然我们仍然非常亲密。但是，当周围每个人似乎都找到了属于自己的人，拥有了这些美妙的爱情故事和经历，有了一个可以一起冒险、分享点滴的人时，我们真的很难不去觉得：是不是我们自己出了什么问题？是不是我们某种程度上不配拥有这些？是不是我们永远不会拥有这一切？
that we're missing out or somehow faulty, and I'm here to say, absolutely none of that is true. Each of us has our own journey and development and healing and growing to do. And maybe your journey right now isn't about finding love. Maybe it's about finding yourself and discovering what you love to do and who you are when you're alone. You have your entire life to be partnered to someone else and to be connected to them financially,
我们是不是错过了什么，或者我们本身有什么缺陷？而我在这里要说的是：绝对没有这回事。我们每个人都有自己的旅程、成长、治愈和发展的过程。也许你现在的旅程并不是关于寻找爱情。也许它是关于寻找你自己，发现你喜欢做什么，以及当你独处时你是谁。你有一生的时间去和一个伴侣结伴，并在财务、
emotionally, socially, intimately. And there will definitely come times in any long-term relationship where we will wish for the days when we were single and only needed to rely on ourselves, only needed to make decisions for ourselves. When you do find someone, I think I can probably definitely say you're going to look back at this moment at some point right now when you're single and you're by yourself, you're thriving, you're independent, and you're going to look back with nostalgia and wish you'd appreciated this time more. When I feel like I want a partner or I'm lacking something because I don't have one, I think about this all the time.
情感、社交、亲密关系上与他们紧密相连。在任何一段长期关系中，肯定都会有这样的时刻：我们会怀念单身的日子，怀念那时只需要依靠自己、只需要为自己做决定的时光。当你真的找到了某个人时，我想我可以相当肯定地说：总有一天，当你回顾当下——此时此刻你单身、你独自一人、你正在蓬勃发展、你很独立——你会带着怀旧的心情回首过去，并希望自己当时能更珍惜这段时光。每当我感觉自己想要一个伴侣、或者因为没有伴侣而觉得有所欠缺时，我总会想到这一点。
It brings me a lot of comfort. But I think that doesn't mean that we're not allowed to have times when we may want a relationship. We don't have to push that feeling away. We don't have to completely deny that kind of desire, that aspect of ourselves in order to be happy and single. I think it's totally okay to crave connection and to want someone. I personally had a moment like that the other day. like I mentioned, this show has gained so many new listeners recently. And to be honest, it can be really overwhelming to feel deserving of this kind of audience
这给了我极大的安慰。但我认为，这并不意味着我们不允许有渴望恋爱的时候。我们不需要把这种感觉推开。为了保持单身并感到快乐，我们不需要彻底否认这种欲望、否认我们身上的这一面。我认为渴望连接、想要有个人陪伴是完全正常的。我个人前几天就经历过这样一刻。正如我所提到的，这个节目最近获得了非常多的新听众。说实话，要觉得自己配得上这种类型的受众，
and to continue to put out episodes that I really want to do without feeling pressure to kind of deliver on what people want to hear. And it honestly made me really emotional. And in that moment, I did wish that I just had someone who loved me to kind of hug me and tell me it was okay and they were proud of me. And yeah, that would have been really nice. But I also realized that that was kind of a learned behavior for me to crave romantic connection in times of stress or when I'm overwhelmed. And just because I don't have that one person doesn't mean I have no one. Just because I can't share good news with a partner doesn't mean I can't share it with my family and my friends.
并且能够继续推出我真正想做、而又不会感到有压力去迎合大家期望的节目，这真的会让人感到压力巨大。说实话，这让我情绪非常激动。而在那一刻，我确实希望自己能有一个爱我的人，能给我一个拥抱，告诉我一切都会好起来的，并告诉他们为我感到骄傲。是的，那真的会很美好。但我也意识到，在压力大或不知所措时渴望浪漫连接，对我来说其实是一种习得的行为。仅仅因为我没有那样一个特定的人，并不意味着我一无所有。仅仅因为我无法与伴侣分享好消息，并不意味着我不能与家人和朋友分享。
Like, for example, like the other day I got this really amazing piece of news and I shared it with my friends. and Kate and her reaction was just as meaningful than if I'd shared the news with any of the people I had dated in the past because that relationship and that friendship I have with her has outlasted all of those people. Her support is unconditional and reliable and it was such a valuable realization for me. You know, no one is missing out just because they're single. And in this episode, I really want to be able to discuss how we can create lives we enjoy and love so much that we're really not bothered by being alone. And the opportunity this period gives us to build a solid foundation for ourselves that
比如，前几天我得到了一个非常棒的好消息，我把它分享给了我的朋友。凯特的反应和如果我把这个消息分享给过去约会过的任何人相比，对我的意义一样重大。因为我和她之间的那种关系和友谊比那些人都要长久。她的支持是无条件且可靠的，这对我来说是一个极其宝贵的觉悟。你知道，没有人会因为单身而错过什么。在这一期节目中，我真的很想探讨我们如何才能创造出如此享受、如此热爱生活，以至于根本不会为独处而烦恼的生活。这段时期为我们提供了机会，让我们为自己建立坚实的基础。
will pay off in the future is something we appreciate, even when we do enter a relationship or if we decide we like being alone, this is such an important period when we're young to be able to really decide what we want and put effort and time into that. There is so much content, so much psychology to discuss today. I'm so excited by the research I found and being able to share this with you so that if you are single right now and maybe feeling a bit lonely or wanting a relationship, you can reframe your relationship with yourself and with romance to realize that really you're kind of all you need to be happy. And you can be the best version of yourself even without a partner. So buckle in. I'm so excited.
这在未来将会得到回报，即使当我们真的进入了一段关系，或者如果我们决定自己更喜欢独处。当我们还年轻时，这是一个如此重要的时期，能够让我们真正决定自己想要什么，并为之投入精力和时间。今天有太多的内容、太多的心理学知识需要讨论了。我对自己的调研成果感到非常兴奋，也很高兴能与大家分享这些，这样如果你现在单身，也许正感到有些孤独或者渴望一段感情，你就可以重塑你与自己、与浪漫的关系，意识到实际上你只需要自己就能获得快乐。即使没有伴侣，你也能成为最好的自己。所以系好安全带吧。我太兴奋了。
And I hope we all learn something today. Okay, so I think that it is a blessing to be single in our 20s. Like I mentioned before, I think our society really seems to have this strange obsession with long-term relationships and marriage and holy matrimony. And yes, that is a beautiful thing. But the flip side of this weird obsession with love and the soulmates and relationships is that for people probably like yourself who are single right now, we can feel like our lives are meaningless unless we have someone else to share it with.
希望我们今天都能有所收获。好的，所以我认为20s单身其实是一种祝福。就像我之前提到的，我觉得我们的社会似乎对长期关系、婚姻和神圣的婚礼有一种奇怪的执念。是的，那是一件美好的事情。但这种对爱情、灵魂伴侣和关系的奇怪执念的另一面是，对于像此时此刻单身的你这样的人来说，我们会觉得自己的生活毫无意义，除非有另一个人来和我们分享。
We may also feel almost pitied or like we are never going to be whole until we've achieved some form of connection or unity with another person. Social norms or societal expectations like this can be really powerful. Societable societal expectations, they're essentially guidelines for our behaviour or expectations placed on us, such as the need to be married, and they kind of cause us to conform with the norm or the status quo of everyone else's behaviour. Often, I think, a justification for an expectation like long-term partnership or commitment is that it leads to a better society, it's
我们甚至可能会觉得自己被同情，或者觉得在与另一个人建立某种形式的连接或结合之前，我们永远不会完整。诸如此类的社会规范或社会期望可能会非常强大。可接受的社会期望，它们本质上是我们行为的指南，或是强加在我们身上的期望，比如需要结婚，它们促使我们去顺应常态，去顺应其他所有人行为的现状。通常我认为，对于长期伴侣或承诺这种期望的一个理由是，它能带来更好的社会，它对我们
better for us, it makes our quality of life better, but we still feel this sense of pressure, this need to conform. And we see this expectation playing out all around us in countless songs and hits about love in romantic comedies where the protagonist is made complete by finding the one in our friendship groups and workplaces in novels and stories about the power of true love. But when it comes to being single, I think the idea that your life is not full until it contains another person is like utterly nonsense and can lead to a lot of stigmatization and negative self-talk for those of us who are alone right now. You can still lead a tremendous, fabulous life whilst you're alone. Also, because we, you know, we're not alone, are we? Like, I think maybe that word has a lot of
更好，能提高我们的生活质量，但我们依然能感受到这种压力，这种需要去顺应的迫切感。我们看到这种期望在身边的无数歌曲中上演，在关于爱情的浪漫喜剧中——主角通过找到“命中注定”而变得完整，在我们的朋友圈和工作场所中，在关于真爱力量的小说和故事中。但当谈到单身时，我认为那种“人生不包含另一个人就不完整”的想法简直是一派胡言，并且会给此时此刻单身我们带来许多污名化和消极的自我对话。即使你独自一人，你依然可以过着精彩绝伦的生活。而且，因为我们，你知道的，我们并不是孤单一人，对吧？我觉得“孤独”这个词可能带有很多
negative connotations, like, I'm alone because I don't have someone, but that's never really the case. Like, you're surrounded by so many people who can support you and provide the encouragement and love that a partner has. And often, in a way that's more sustainable, and fulfilling, then if you do decide to date someone who's not right for you, just to enjoy the feeling that you have a partner. In fact, it's a proven fact, a proven fact people, that it's not just our partners or those we are in relationships with that create happiness, but the quality of our relationships with our friends and our families. In fact, while I was researching this episode, I found this study that was done by a number of positive psychologists. Positive is a
消极的含义，比如：因为没有人陪伴，所以我很孤独。但事实并非如此。因为你被许多人包围着，他们可以支持你，提供伴侣所能给予的鼓励和爱。而且通常这种支持会更具可持续性、更能带来充实感，这远胜于你仅仅为了享受“有伴侣”的感觉而去和某个并不适合你的人约会。事实上，这是一个被证实的事实，朋友们，被证实的事实：带来幸福的不仅是我们的伴侣或恋爱对象，还有我们与朋友和家人关系的质量。事实上，在研究这一期节目时，我发现了一项由多位积极心理学家进行的研究。“积极”是
field within psychology, not just an adjective to describe these researchers, but they determined that it is our positive emotional experiences with people across our lives that is the largest predictor of happiness. One person is not going to be enough to make you happy. You need to feel properly supported and loved by people from all areas of your life. So let us talk about some of the amazing benefits of being single in your 20s, and some of the great opportunities it gives us to kind of counteract some of those inner doubts and internalized expectations that come from society. First of all, it might actually be the case that singleness actually makes us happier in the long run.
心理学中的一个领域，而不仅仅是用来描述这些研究人员的形容词。他们确定，我们在生活中与人们的积极情感体验，才是幸福感的最大预测因素。单凭一个人是无法让你快乐的。你需要从生活各个领域的人那里感受到真正的支持和爱。所以让我们来谈谈20s单身的几个惊人好处，以及它为我们提供的一些绝佳机会，用以抵消社会带来的那些内心怀疑和内化的期望。首先，单身实际上在长远来看可能会让我们更快乐。
So this study, done by a professor of behavioral science out of London, found that single women with no children are actually generally happier than those who are married. or those who have children. This person, this professor reported that these people, these single women, have more free time, greater independence, more money, and an overall sense of well-being. But for men and for my male listeners, I know that's not many of you, but the opposite is actually the case. It seems that men actually benefit more from marriage and partnership than women.
这项由伦敦一位行为科学教授进行的研究发现，没有孩子的单身女性通常比已婚女性或有孩子的女性更快乐。这个人，这位教授报告说，这些人——也就是单身女性——拥有更多空闲时间、更大的独立性、更多的金钱，以及整体的幸福感。但对于男性和我的男听众来说——我知道人数可能不多——情况恰恰相反。似乎男性实际上比女性更能从婚姻和伴侣关系中获益。
And men who are in long-term relationships are actually my own. marginally happier than those who are not. So obviously these statements are quite controversial and were met with quite a bit of criticism, which I get, it's understandable. If you are a married woman, you probably aren't going to take too kindly to someone telling you that you are destined to misery because you happen to find someone you love. And I hope that we all know that's not what I'm saying here. And I think the biggest lesson to take away from this is that happiness is relative and it's not the case that singleness is in no uncertain terms going to make you miserable. In fact, from this research, it actually seems it's the opposite. I also don't think we can assume that
处于长期关系中的男性实际上稍微——只是稍微——比那些没有的人更快乐。所以很显然，这些说法相当具有争议性，也遭到了一些批评，我能理解，这可以理解。如果你是一个已婚女性，听到有人对你说“因为你碰巧找到了你爱的人，所以你注定要悲惨一生”，你大概不会觉得太好受。我希望我们大家都知道，这并不是我在这里要表达的意思。我认为从中学到的最大教训是：幸福是相对的，单身并不意味着毫无疑问会让你痛苦。事实上，从这项研究来看，情况似乎恰恰相反。我也不认为我们可以假设
what this research is saying is that people in relationships are necessarily sad and depressed and dissatisfied. It's definitely a case-by-case basis and I think there are so many people out there who are in awful relationships that might actually pull down the average, noting that I think it's always better to be alone than in the company of someone or in a relationship that is not serving you or is toxic or nasty. That is a really good segue, I think, into exploring some of the other emotional, social, intellectual, spiritual benefits of singleness in our 20s. Firstly, you have time to discover who you are and to improve yourself. Let's be really honest here. Relationships take up a lot of time. If you are committed to a person and getting to know them and sharing your life with
这项研究是在说处于恋爱中的人就一定悲伤、沮丧和不满意。这绝对要视具体情况而定。而且我认为外面有那么多处于糟糕关系中的人，这实际上可能会拉低平均水平。请记住，我一直认为：独自一人，总好过和那些不适合你、有毒或恶劣的人在一起，或者处于不健康的关系中。我认为这是一个很好的过渡，可以去探索20s单身的其它情感、社交、智力、精神方面的好处。首先，你有时间去发现真正的自我并提升自我。我们实话实说吧。恋爱会占用大量的时间。如果你致力于一个人，去了解他们并与他们分享你的生活，
them, that is going to require a large investment of your time and your energy. And, you know, you also want to be around them all the time. I'm sure a lot of us can understand that feeling of falling in love and never wanting to be away from that person. But sometimes that comes at a cost. When you're single, you get to use that time that you would otherwise have spent with partner to focus only on you and what feeds your soul and allows you to grow. And I think this really perfectly links to our next point. Being single in our 20s gives us more time to focus on our dreams and our ambitions, more time to study, to go to the gym, to pursue a new hobby, to spend time on our career.
那将需要你投入大量的时间和精力。而且，你知道的，你也会想一直和他们在一起。我相信我们很多人都能理解那种坠入爱河、一分一秒都不想离开对方的感觉。但有时这是有代价的。当你单身时，你可以利用原本会花在伴侣身上的时间，完全专注于你自己、专注于那些滋养你灵魂并促使你成长的事物。我认为这非常完美地连接到了我们的下一个观点。在20s单身给了我们更多时间去专注于我们的梦想和雄心，更多时间去学习、去健身房、去追求新的爱好、去专注我们的事业。
So, fun fact, I actually started this podcast after a breakup with a long-term partner when I was feeling really shit about being alone and had all of this spare time I didn't really know what to do with. And being single gave me so many evenings to create episodes I loved and to be able to create something I was proud of. And we rarely get the time in our lives where we can be entirely selfish and we're able to really focus on the core foundations of our lives to create something that we're proud of or focus on a major goal. When you're single, that's one of the huge upsides. You get the opportunity to explore new things, new hobbies, to practice self-love,
所以，一个有趣的事实是：我实际上是在与一个长期伴侣分手后才开始做这个播客的。当时我对独自一人感到非常糟糕，而且有这么多的空闲时间，我甚至不知道该拿它们怎么办。单身给了我许多个夜晚去创作我喜爱的节目，并创作出让我引以为豪的东西。在生活中，我们很少有时间能够完全自私，能够真正专注于生活核心基础来创造让我们骄傲的事物，或者专注于某个重大目标。当你单身时，这就是巨大的优势之一。你有机会探索新鲜事物、培养新爱好、练习自爱、
to go on solo adventures and travel and not be distracted by a relationship. Essentially, you get to figure shit out on your own, and you get to figure it out by yourself and be your own person. I don't know, I don't know if you noticed this, but sometimes they see couples or people who've been together for a long time, and they don't know how to live without each other. They don't have their own aspirations or their own goals. They kind of meld into one person.
进行一个人的冒险和旅行，而不会被恋爱关系分心。本质上，你可以自己去搞清楚状况，靠自己把事情弄明白，成为真正的自己。我不知道，我不知道你们有没有注意到这一点：有时我们会看到情侣或那些在一起很长时间的人，他们不知道没有彼此该怎么生活。他们没有自己的抱负或目标。他们不知不觉融合成了一个人。
When you're single for a longer period of time, you get the opportunity to figure out what you want and how you feel there's no one to compromise with. You're not attached to someone else. Your identity isn't kind of melded with theirs. Another perk, you can do whatever you want. Like, you can go and get ice cream like right now. You don't have to tell anyone. You can eat wherever you want for dinner. every single night of the week. You don't have to visit in-laws. You know, decision-making is so much
当你单身较长一段时间时，你就有机会弄清楚自己想要什么、自己的感受如何，因为不需要向任何人妥协。你没有依附于其他人。你的身份没有和他们的身份混为一谈。另一个好处是，你想干什么就干什么。比如，你现在就可以去买个冰淇淋。你不需要告诉任何人。一周里的每一天，你都可以在任何你想去的餐馆吃晚饭。你不需要去拜访公公婆婆。你知道的，做决定要容易得多。
easier. And another perk, especially if you're someone who's maybe been in a long-term relationship before or after that, is that you don't have to share money. Like, I'm sure not all couples do this, but it is an expectation, especially if you're getting married or you're getting really serious. But when you're single, like, that money is all yours. You are completely kind of independent in your finances. You're going to make your own decisions. Like, okay, you want to go and spend $100 at Sephora or whatever. Like, that's fine. You're not saving for a house with anyone. You're, you don't have to answer to anyone about how you spend your finances. And I know it's not the 1950s. And if you're someone who is in a relationship listening to this, I hope you're not
还有一个好处，特别是对于那些以前有过长期恋爱经历或者刚结束恋情的人来说，你不需要共享金钱。嗯，我敢肯定并不是所有情侣都这样做，但这是一种期望，特别是如果你要结婚或者关系变得非常认真。但当你单身时，这些钱全都是你自己的。你的财务状况是完全独立的。你可以自己做决定。比如，好吧，你想在丝芙兰花100美元或随便什么东西上。没关系。你不需要和任何人一起存钱买房子。你不需要就如何花钱向任何人交代。我知道现在不是20世纪50年代了。如果你正在听这个节目并且处于恋爱中，我希望你不会被冒犯。我知道女性对自己的金钱拥有独立自主权，但这确实是需要考虑的一点。
offended. I know that women have independence over their money, but it is something to consider. another really big upside is you get to practice complete independence. Now, as we know as good students of psychology, hyper independence can actually be quite harmful and it's often a coping mechanism or response to trauma. That's not really what we're talking about here. So hyper independence is like really not being able to depend on anyone, not being able to trust anyone and it often arises as a result of deep emotional baggage by portrayal or abandonment, a sense of unsafe around other previous relationships.
另一个非常大的优势是，你可以练习彻底的独立。现在，正如我们作为优秀的心理学学生所知，过度独立实际上可能相当有害，它通常是应对创伤的一种应对机制或反应。这并不是我们在这里讨论的重点。所以过度独立就像是完全无法依赖任何人、无法信任任何人，这通常是由于背叛或抛弃带来的深刻情感包袱、以及对以往恋爱关系的不安全感而产生的。
You know, if you've been cheated on or hurt by a partner, often our reaction to that is to become hyper-independent and to need no one. And it results in you really struggling to build deep connections and rely on others out of fear of being hurt even when you want to. but a little bit of independence is always good I think especially in your 20s you know you learn to trust yourself you learn how to regulate your emotions on your own how to do things alone which is so amazing and you know that no matter what happens you can always do it by yourself and be perfectly fine no matter what that is such an important thing to recognize and acknowledge and
你知道，如果你曾被伴侣劈腿或伤害过，我们对此的反应往往是变得过度独立，不需要任何人。这会导致你即使在内心渴望时，也难以建立深度的连接，并且因为害怕受伤而无法依靠他人。但是，一点点独立总是好的，我认为尤其是在20s，你知道如何信任自己，你知道如何独自调节情绪，如何独自完成事情，这太棒了。而且你知道无论发生什么，你总是可以靠自己，并且无论如何都能过得很好。这是一个非常重要的需要去认识和承认的事情，
it makes you stronger. I think another huge benefit I've noticed in my own personal life and on anecdotal level from friends is the deep connections you're able to build with the people around you, especially your close friends. One of the major benefits of being single and being happy in your 20s is having the time to spend with your friends. And it actually increases the number of social connections you might have. So there was this interesting study that basically concluded that people who are single actually have more social connections and more independent social connections. That's because when we don't have a relationship, we don't have a primary relationship. We kind of need to reach out more to your connections and your social networks because those are
它会让你变得更强大。我认为我在自己的个人生活中以及从朋友身上注意到的另一个巨大好处是，你能够与周围的人、特别是你的密友建立深度的连接。在20s单身并感到快乐的主要好处之一，就是拥有与朋友相处的时间。这实际上会增加你的社交连接数量。曾有一项有趣的有趣研究得出的结论是：单身的人实际上拥有更多的社交连接和更独立的社交连接。这是因为当我们没有恋爱关系时，我们没有所谓的“首要关系”。我们反而需要更多地向身边的连接和社交网络伸出援手，因为这些人将为我们提供所需的支持，而不是去依靠伴侣，
the people who are going to provide us with the support that we need rather than, you know, our partner rather than like your married counterpart or someone who is by your side. And I don't think we can understate the importance of strong friendships, regardless of your relationship status. But I think a lot of us would see that when we are alone and when we don't have a partner, immediately one of the first things we do is call up our friends, spend so much more time with them, get to go out and party or stay in and paint. Like whatever you want to do, you're able to cultivate those friendships.
而不是像已婚人士或身边有伴侣的人那样。无论你的恋爱状态如何，我们都不能低估坚固友谊的重要性。但我认为我们很多人都会发现：当我们孤身一人、没有伴侣时，我们立刻会做的第一件事就是打电话给朋友，花更多时间陪伴他们，出去派对或者待在家里画画。无论你想做什么，你都能够培养那些友谊。
Let's not forget, it's not just friendships you get to develop, but other types of relationships. When you're not in a committed relationship, there is often, you know, often in a committed relationship as this norm of being exclusive or only having sex with each other. Obviously, if you're in an open relationship, that may be different. But for most of us who are single, we get the opportunity to have sex with whoever we want, whenever we want it. Like we get the freedom to explore new sexual partners and meet people and be sexually adventurous. Maybe that's not your cup of tea, totally okay. But sometimes it's really liberating to be with new people and to try new
别忘了，你不仅能发展友谊，还能发展其他类型的关系。当你没有处于承诺关系中时，通常在承诺关系中存在一种保持排他性或只与彼此发生性关系的规范。显然，如果你处于开放式关系中，情况可能会有所不同。但对于我们大多数单身的人来说，我们有机会和任何我们想的人发生性关系，无论何时想都可以。我们拥有探索新的性伴侣、结识新朋友并进行性冒险的自由。也许这不合你的胃口，完全没关系。但有时，和新人们在一起、尝试新事物真的非常解放。
things out. And sometimes we just need to be alone to unlearn habits or patterns that are emotionally unhealthy. So when my last situation, like relationship thing, whatever we want to call it, when it ended, I realized that in my pursuit of love, I'd kind of acted in a way that I didn't like. I neglected friendships and important people in my life. And it was a really hard truth that I had to acknowledge about myself, that I craved romantic love above everything else, so much so that I was really willing to sacrifice important things to me just to be with someone who didn't really have to give anything up and got all the benefits while I really lost out and it cost me. So I made this conscious decision to take a break and to focus on myself, to unlearn this dependency mindset I had,
有时我们只是需要独处来改掉那些在情感上不健康的习惯或模式。所以当我的上一段暧昧关系——或者不管我们怎么称呼它——结束时，我意识到在追求爱情的过程中，我做了一些自己并不喜欢的事。我忽视了生活中的友谊和重要的人。这是一个我不得不承认的关于我自己的残酷真相：我将浪漫爱情置于一切之上，甚至愿意牺牲对我来说很重要的东西，只为了和某人在一起。而对方其实并不需要放弃任何东西，却获得了所有的好处，而我却真正失去了所有，付出了代价。所以我做出有意识的决定：休息一段时间，专注于自我，改掉我那种依赖心态，
this unconscious need to be loved and admired and craved. And I had to take a step back and deliberately heal the insecurities that had caused this. And, you know, here we are now. And, So I think I've done a bit of learning from that situation and I wouldn't have been able to do it if immediately after that situation ship had ended, I jumped into something new. I think if that had been the case, I would have ended up in the exact same situation with the exact same type of person, never having developed the resilience to move on, never having been able to address the real reason that I was attached to these people. I think of the, you know, of all the amazing upsides of being single and alone and happy is the relationship that you get to cultivate with yourself. And really, at the end of the day, our relationship with our self is the most important one you're going to have in your entire life.
这种对被爱、被仰慕和被渴望的无意识需求。我不得不退后一步，刻意治愈导致这一切的不安全感。然后，你知道的，我们现在就在这里。所以我想我从那段经历中吸取了一些教训，如果在那段暧昧关系结束后我立刻投入到新的关系中，我是绝对做不到这一点的。如果真是那样的话，我最终会陷入完全相同的处境，遇到完全相同类型的人，永远无法培养出继续前进的韧性，也永远无法解决我依恋这些人的真正原因。我认为，单身、独处且快乐的所有惊人优势中，最棒的就是你将与自己培养的关系。说到底，我们与自己的关系是你一生中所拥有的最重要的关系。
It's the, you know, like when you think about it, the only one that really lasts, that's never going to disappear, it's never going to abandon us or go away. So consider it your greatest investment and take this time to focus on yourself, focus on your hobbies, focus on your goals. Because one day you might look back at this glorious, sacred time and regret that you didn't appreciate it more. Regret that you didn't recognize the opportunity that you had. I think it's okay if despite all of this, despite all of these benefits and pros and whatever, you still want to relationship. But I don't think it should be our entire focus. You can still believe that you deserve to be loved, deserve that you can be treated right and not settle, and also appreciate and love your
它是，你知道的，仔细想想，它是唯一真正持久的关系，它永远不会消失，永远不会抛弃我们或离我们而去。所以把它当作你最伟大的投资，利用这段时间专注于自己，专注于你的爱好，专注于你的目标。因为总有一天，你会回首这段辉煌、神圣的时光，并后悔自己当时没有更珍惜它。后悔自己没有认识到你所拥有的机会。我认为，尽管有这一切，尽管有所有的这些好处、优点等等，如果你仍然想要一段感情，这也是可以理解的。但这不应该成为我们的全部焦点。你依然可以相信自己值得被爱、值得被正确对待而不将就，同时也去欣赏和热爱你的
single life. In fact, I think it really goes hand in hand. But why is it that even when we are really happy being alone, everything is going right, everything is going well, we have friends, we're doing really well, we've got opportunities, we feel healthy, we feel happy, we really feel complete. Why is it that even in those moments we still crave affection and romantic love? Why is it that we still feel incomplete sometimes? Well, this is a psychology podcast, so of course I really want to give a psychological explanation for this. Romantic love gives us the same dopamine rush and hit as things that cause major euphoria and ecstasy,
单身生活。事实上，我认为这二者是相辅相成的。但为什么即使当我们非常享受独处、一切都顺风顺水、一切都很好、有朋友、过得很棒、拥有机会、感觉健康、感到快乐、真正感到圆满时——为什么即使在那些时刻，我们仍然渴望affection（温存）和浪漫爱情呢？为什么有时我们仍然会感到不完整呢？好吧，这是一个心理学播客，所以理所当然地，我想为这种现象给出一个心理学解释。浪漫爱情带给我们的多巴胺飙升和快感，与那些能引发强烈欣快感和狂喜的事物是一样的，
like ecstasy or drugs like sugar. like things that get our neurons firing. And because we become accustomed to that, well, we're kind of dependent on that feeling of that rush and that level of dopamine in our brains from getting hugs and attention and affection from a partner. That's why it's so hard to move on after a breakup and to really embrace being single
比如摇头丸或糖分之类的药物。就像那些让我们的神经元活跃起来的事物一样。因为我们已经习惯了那种状态，嗯，我们某种程度上对那种冲刺感、以及从伴侣的拥抱、关注和温存中获得的脑内多巴胺水平产生了依赖。这就是为什么在分手后很难释怀、很难真正拥抱单身状态的原因，
because we're going through literal withdrawal from a long series of consistent dopamine spikes from someone else. and it's totally okay to still want that feeling. We also need affection to live. It's crucial for the release of oxytocin, which is a hormone that plays a really important role in bonding and intimacy and even repairing connections in our brain. It's the hormone that makes you feel love and trust,
因为我们正在经历来自他人的一连串持续多巴胺峰值的字面意义上的戒断反应。并且，仍然渴望那种感觉是完全正常的。我们也需要温存才能生存。这对于催产素的释放至关重要，催产素是一种在建立联结、亲密感甚至修复大脑连接中扮演极其重要角色的激素。它是让你感受到爱与信任的激素，
and some studies have also associated it with the bond of mother has with her child through childbirth. Without oxytocin, we could feel really empty. part of the kind of hormonal neurotransmitter equation within our brain that makes us feel content and happy. So if you're not getting it from a romantic partner and you're still craving that connection, you might need to find other ways to restore the feeling it elicits by doing something else like hugging a friend, listening to emotional music, having a warm shower, getting a massage, telling someone in your life how much you love them. And I think this leads on to what I want to talk about to conclude the episode, which is how do we cultivate self-love whilst you're single
并且一些研究还将其与母亲通过分娩与孩子建立的纽带联系起来。没有催产素，我们可能会感到非常空虚。它是我们大脑中让我们感到满足和快乐的荷尔蒙神经递质方程式的一部分。所以，如果你没有从浪漫伴侣那里获得这种感受，并且仍然渴望这种连接，你可能需要通过做其他事情来恢复它所引发的感觉，比如拥抱朋友、听感性的音乐、洗个热水澡、做个按摩、或者对生活中的某个人说你有多爱他们。我认为这就顺理成章地引出了我想在节目结尾讨论的内容：如何在单身的同时培养自爱，
and how do we cultivate an appreciation for being alone? I think first and foremost, all that love that you want to give to a partner, pour it into yourself, into your friends, into your family. Take this really valuable time to build deep connections with the people around you, to treat them the way you would treat a romantic partner to give them gifts, to tell them you love them, to spend quality time with them. And that's going to pay off in dividends in the future, regardless of whether there's a relationship in your future or not. I think like that study we talked about earlier, having supportive quality relationships is like the biggest indicator of happiness and well-being. So you're not going to lose out if you spend all time with your
以及我们该如何培养对独处的欣赏。我认为首先也是最重要的一点：把你想要给予伴侣的所有爱，倾注到你自己身上，倾注到你的朋友和家人身上。利用这段极其宝贵的时光，与周围的人建立深度的连接，像对待浪漫伴侣那样对待他们，送他们礼物，告诉他们你爱他们，花高质量的时间陪伴他们。这在未来将带来丰厚的回报，无论你的未来是否有恋爱关系。我认为就像我们之前讨论的那项研究一样，拥有支持性的高质量关系是幸福感和福祉的最大指标。所以，如果你把所有时间都花在朋友身上、并真正努力促进这些关系，你绝不会有什么损失。
friends and really trying to promote those relationships. Being single, having a period of singleness is an amazing time to pursue a hobby or a long-term goal and to practice self-improvement. It also puts your mind and your focus back onto yourself rather than on others. I think a lot of people, like, they go through breakups and they're like, I'm going to get really fit at the gym. Do whatever you want. Whatever's going to make you happy, but there's a reason that happens. because suddenly you're not distracted by this other person. Suddenly you have all of this time. You're not needing to think about them and think about their actions
单身、拥有单身时期是追求爱好或长期目标、并进行自我提升的绝佳时间。它也能让你的心灵和注意力重新回到自己身上，而不是放在别人身上。我认为很多人，比如，他们经历分手后会说：“我要去健身房练出好身材。”随你便吧。任何能让你快乐的事都可以，但这种现象发生是有原因的。因为突然之间你不再被另一个人分心。突然之间你拥有了所有这些时间。你不需要去考虑他们、考虑他们的行为、
and what's going to impact them and spend time with them. All of that energy gets put back onto yourself. And you're able to refocus on what you want to achieve, what's going to matter to you in two or five, ten years. And it's a great period of time to set a really big goal. Maybe you want to run a marathon. on what a great thing to do you i think you should do that i think you should do that and now you have all this time there's no nobody distracting you there's nothing getting in your way to really focus on yourself
考虑什么会影响到他们、花时间陪伴他们。所有的能量都重新回到了你自己身上。并且你能够重新专注于你想要实现的目标，专注于在两、五、十年内对你真正重要的事情。这是一个设定伟大目标的绝佳时期。也许你想跑马拉松。多棒的一件事啊，我觉得你应该去做。我觉得你就应该去跑马拉松，现在你拥有了所有这些时间，没有任何人分散你的注意力，没有任何事情阻碍你真正专注于自己。
i think also it's important to change our mindset rather than being like i'm lonely i don't have anyone i'm missing out like valentine's day sucks christmas sucks i really wish someone was there for me treat this period like it's a growth period like it is important for your development, which it is. Be like, this is actually a major blessing. Switch that mindset from like a loss mindset to a gain mindset. Like this is an amazing opportunity. Not everyone gets this opportunity to be able to completely and utterly focus on the things
我认为改变心态也很重要，不要总觉得我很孤独、我一无所有、我错过了什么，比如情人节糟透了、圣诞节糟透了、我真的很希望有人能陪在我身边。相反，把这段时期当作一个成长时期，它对你的个人发展至关重要，事实也确实如此。告诉自己，这其实是一个重大的福气。把这种心态从“失去的心态”转变为“收获的心态”。这绝对是一个绝佳的机会。并不是每个人都有机会能够完全、彻底地专注于那些
that make you happy and make you grow. And I think the final thing is know that even if you find your person, you are still entirely complete without them. And practicing self-love, practicing self-improvement, creating a life that you want to live, that is such an important, important goal. And you might even be happier and healthier without someone to join you along in that journey.
能让你快乐、让你成长的事务。我认为最后一点是，你要明白，即使你找到了对的人，没有他们，你也是完全完整的。练习自爱、练习自我提升、创造你想过的生活，这是一个非常非常重要的目标。而且，如果没有人加入你的旅程，你可能会过得更快乐、更健康。
It's something that will benefit you in the future. It cannot be understated. And it's going to really set you up and make you an incredibly happy version of yourself. I think the best part of not having to share your life with someone is that you get to prioritize yourself, you get to enjoy yourself, you get to set the agenda.
这是会对你未来受益匪浅的事情。这一点怎么强调都不为过。它真的会为你奠定基础，让你成为一个极其快乐的自己。我认为不用和别人分享生活的最棒的一点就是，你可以优先考虑自己，你可以享受自己，你可以自己安排日程。
And I think that it doesn't mean you have to be happy all the time. It doesn't mean that you don't want that occasionally. But being able to adapt to loneliness is a skill and it's a practice that becomes stronger over time and as we appreciate where we are and the importance of where we are now more and more, you're really able to see that being alone and being single and without a relationship is not a loss. It's actually a huge win. And there are so many things that you get to do that maybe others in relationships don't.
我觉得这并不意味着你必须一直快乐。这并不意味着你偶尔不会渴望陪伴。但是，能够适应孤独是一种技能，也是一种练习，它会随着时间的推移而变得更强大；随着我们越来越欣赏我们所处的位置以及当下所在的重要意义，你会真正发现，孤身一人、保持单身且没有恋爱并不是一种损失。实际上，这是一个巨大的胜利。而且有那么多事情，你是可以去做的，而身处恋爱中的人可能做不到。
There's so many hours in the day to spend on yourself and to spend on the relationship you have with yourself. So if you are someone who is struggling with this at the moment, someone who's feeling insecure or self-down about the fact that you might not have someone in your life, I hope this helped you out. I hope that this kind of set you on a good path and you're able to appreciate what this kind of period means for you and you're able to appreciate yourself and your relationship with yourself more and set some long-term goals for yourself. Think big. Cultivate your friendships. try a new hobby, try anything you want to do. Like, there's nothing stopping you. That's the amazing blessing of this.
一天中有那么多的时间可以花在自己身上，花在你与自己的关系上。所以，如果你现在正为此苦恼，如果你因为生活中可能没有伴侣而感到不安或自我否定，我希望这能对你有所帮助。我希望这能让你走上一条好的道路，让你能够感激这段时期对你的意义，能够更多地欣赏自己以及你与自己的关系，并为自己设定一些长期目标。放眼大局。培养你的友谊。尝试一个新的爱好，尝试任何你想做的事。真的，没有什么能阻止你。这就是它令人惊叹的福气。
And thank you so much for listening. I hope you enjoyed this episode. Thank you for choosing it if you voted on the poll of my Instagram. Thank you so much. It was an absolute pleasure to be able to talk about it and do this research. I especially love when topics relate to something I'm going through. Like, I think it's so universal to struggle with these feelings. you're not alone and you're not a bad person, you're not a weak person because you want love.
非常感谢大家的收听。希望你们喜欢这一期节目。谢谢你们在我的Instagram投票中选择了它。非常感谢。能够谈论这个话题并做这项研究绝对是一种荣幸。我特别喜欢那些与我正在经历的事情相关的主题。我觉得，为这些情感所困扰是非常普遍的现象。你并不孤单，你也不是一个坏人，你并没有因为渴望爱而变得软弱。
That is such a crucial element of being a human. But you can get love from so many places and I hope you know you're not alone in that feeling and it's all going to work out. So thank you so much for listening. Hopefully I'll hear or you'll hear me next week. You'll be back for another episode. And as always, if you feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify or wherever
那是作为人类至关重要的一部分。但你可以在很多地方获得爱，我希望你知道在那种感觉上你并不孤单，一切都会好起来的。所以非常感谢大家的收听。希望下周还能听到你们的声音，或者你们能听到我。你们会回来收听另一期节目。一如既往，如果你觉得愿意的话，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方留下五星好评
you get your podcast. If you don't want to, that's fine. But if you feel cool to do so, it is an amazing way to help this show grow. And thank you again. I will see you next week. On the Look Back at It Podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite offers. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
如果你不想的话也没关系。但如果你愿意这么做，这是帮助这个节目成长的好方法。再次谢谢大家。我们下周见。这里是Look Back at It Podcast。在1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是Sam J，我是Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的嘉宾一起，弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。就像Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代一样。那是一个疯狂的年代。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are on? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的Learn the Hard Way。这个节目主要探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人一直背负着防备心理？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Learn the Hard Way。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个男人经历过同样的事情。
Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Love Trapped播客。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。